there is a insane new video of rudy
giuliani uh we talked about rudy
giuliani earlier in the week and just
like do we feel bad for him do we not a
lot of his current problems are really
of his own doing choosing to get
involved with trump and choosing to
defend trump and choosing to fly around
the country filing these bogus
complaints and holding bogus hearings
related to the 2020 election and rudy
giuliani is potentially in a bunch of
trouble now
he still appears to be sort of
maintaining his loyalty to trump at
least for now even though for most
reports we've seen trump has more or
less abandoned rudy giuliani and the
latest is that rudy giuliani claims to
have evidence
related to hillary clinton in either his
bedroom or his den now den we could talk
about is a den a living room but maybe
without a television or how do we define
den doesn't really matter rudy says on
newsmax he has evidence in his bedroom
and then he says actually it's in my den
and everything about this is really
weird because it is essentially a
confession from rudy giuliani which i
will explain
huffpost reports rudy giuliani reveals
location of secret evidence stash the
former new york city mayor makes a weird
confession on live tv
giuliani declared tuesday he has a stash
of secret evidence against former
secretary of state hillary clinton and
it's in his bedroom and then he says
actually it's in my den this was an
interview on the right wing news max
network he says he has a thousand pieces
of evidence that no one has seen
and of course as you might remember
rudy giuliani's
home and rudy giuliani's office were
raided and so if there is quote evidence
there it raises the question as to did
he legally
hold that back or hide it in some way
here is rudy on newsmax explaining to us
exactly where the evidence is well how
do i think trump
knew i knew about it back then
i can't tell you exactly how but i know
how he knew about it back then there's a
lot more to come out
this is not i mean
what you're
they may feel that it's gobbledygook
but it's
supported by about a thousand pieces of
evidence none of which have been
revealed yet wow i happen to have it in
my bedroom
or my den actually
i've had it there for years as well
so so there's a bunch of different
things here and it all is the continued
self-inflicted damage being done by rudy
giuliani first question did he break the
law by withholding this supposed
evidence like this is if if he if the
evidence exists right and i know you
guys all the first thing is is this even
in the
universe of truth
if it is did rudy giuliani break the law
by withholding this supposed evidence
that's question number one
uh second question
is he willing to present this supposed
evidence in court while under oath
because all of these guys and gals for
years claim to have all of this evidence
here there the other place it's always
imminently going to be released and this
will be hillary clinton's undoing or
this will be joe biden's undoing or this
will be the vindication of trump we've
got the evidence and then it never
actually gets
released or presented or introduced in
any kind of serious way under oath in a
court of law or submitted as an exhibit
and it's very common for these
right-wingers to claim they have
evidence and that it's it's just about
to come out and then we never see it and
look at what happened with the 2020
election they've been claiming on the
2020 election that they have evidence
that's gonna just blow the socks off of
this election it'll flip arizona it'll
flip michigan it'll flip georgia it's
it's
mind-blowing what they have they've been
claiming it for 15 months and it never
does and if they have it they've also
not included it in any of the court
filings related to the 2020 election all
of which are found to be without merit
and it's very similar with other liars
and grifters mike pillow mike lindell
the ceo of mypillow
he has mountains of evidence he has
cyber evidence he has forensic evidence
voting machine all of this different
stuff and nobody has seen it
nobody has seen it so
then you have to step step back and
think about the political donald trump
has been running against hillary clinton
since 2015 and he continues to run
against her even though he's not running
for anything and she's not running for
anything he continues the hillary
clinton stuff do any of us believe
that if rudy giuliani had a thousand
pieces of evidence against hillary
clinton it wouldn't have come out when
trump was actually running against her
come on guys it doesn't make any sense
and this stuff plays really well on the
conservative news channels but obviously
they would have used the evidence if
they had it at any time during the 2016
campaign during the 2020 campaign
recently the goal right now is
distraction and distortion things are
not looking good for giuliani things it
hasn't been a particularly good week to
two weeks for donald trump what would
the flushing documents done down the
toilet and all of these other different
things and it is obfuscation distraction
distortion look at this shiny thing i
claim exists but there's no evidence it
actually does if you believe that rudy
genuinely has evidence
about anything honestly at this point
find me on twitter at dpakman and let me
know what you think he has but more
importantly why he has not yet released
it i look forward to hearing from you
i am someone who loves documentaries i
would imagine many of you love them as
well you've got to check out our sponsor
curiosity stream it's the only streaming
platform dedicated to documentaries i'm
always noticing curiosity stream has the
best selection of documentaries better
than netflix or any other platform and
the best part is it's only 15 bucks a
year when you click the link below and
use the code pacman which is an amazing
deal it's nearly endless documentary
content and whether you want to tune out
and watch something relaxing dive into
something really thought provoking
curiosity stream has both and everything
in between
i just got done watching pompeii
which is unbelievable i visited pompeii
when i was in italy and the documentary
filled in so much fascinating history
about it and the people who lived there
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 office subscription that comes out to
14.99 a year a year go to
curiositystream.compacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below